[Music]
all right antonio brown he apparently
would like to be a member of the san
francisco 49ers he's told jerry rice
that according to jerry rice and antonio
crown on instagram had a photoshop of
him in a 49ers uniform embracing jerry
rice i know when we talked to terrell
owens a few weeks ago it was pretty
clear number one that brown wants out of
pittsburgh and number two he was asking
t.o a lot of questions about the bay
area so
maybe he's with the 49ers maybe with
someone else i don't think he's going to
be in pittsburgh ed bouchette was on
yesterday he's covered the steelers for
decades with the pittsburgh post gazette
he says they just need to take whatever
they can get and move on so if they as
of march 17 that's the day two and a
half million dollars is due to be paid
to antonio brown if they take the best
offer on the table who is the best team
to acquire antonio brown that's today's
draft kristen go ahead and flip the coin
big cat calls tails and we'll see it
it'll come up tails and he'll defer to
me we know how this drill goes so there
goes the coin the drama is killing me
the suspense is palpable and it's heads
all right i'll defer to you
wow
i'm stunned i'm stunned i wasn't ready
for this okay
are we saying that he's definitely being
traded can i pick one of my pictures of
steelers
i i you can pick any team you want you
can pick an aaf team if you want to you
can go with the the san antonio or
whoever they are got it so my first pick
will be the pittsburgh steelers because
this drama
it's just drama all the time antonio
brown has wanted to be traded a billion
times at this point i still think there
is a world where the steelers say big
ben he's not getting younger we need to
do we need to try to cobble this thing
back together and take one more shot at
a super bowl run with this core with
this coach with this quarterback so my
number one spot would be for antonio
brown to go to the pittsburgh steelers
maybe that's maybe actually i just found
something genius you tell antonio brown
you've been traded to the pittsburgh
steelers
if he's just like oh great
and just start new
right uh do a big press
conference yeah look here here's the
problem he wants out and even if you can
convince him to say okay i'll stay now
because they have to get this resolved
by march 17 when the two and a half
million comes due
if he says okay i'll give it another
shot there's no guarantee he's going to
continue to feel that way there's no
guarantee that that he and ben
roethlisberger are going to get along
and that's the core of the problem it's
him and roethlisberger wait but mike he
asked for a trade in like am i am i
taking crazy pills antonio brown asked
for a trade in the middle of last season
it was actually the beginning of the
season like during the season so he
joked he joked about it he joked about a
former pr employee like if you think
that then trade me like do the former pr
employee of the steelers made some
comment about like we really don't need
him we can get it done without him or if
you think that then trade me i mean he
didn't really ask for a trade until
after the season but this is all in the
same relative space of time look
something is broken between brown and
the steelers and i think the last thing
you do if you're the steelers is force
it together they keep finding great
receivers in the middle to late rounds
of the draft i would just trust that
you're going to find another great
receiver and say see you later antonio
brown
okay all right so that's my first pick i
think the steelers will still try to
cobble this thing back together and be
like let's let's let's get everyone on
the same page for one more year
all right i'm gonna go with the team
that he wants to play for because i
think one of the key ingredients in
having a happy and productive antonio
brown is to give him what he wants he
doesn't want pittsburgh he wants to play
for the 49ers fine trading with the
49ers they the word just came out that
the 49ers aren't picking up the option
on pierre garcon so it would be marquise
goodwin and antonio brown and george
kittle and it feels like that that would
make the most sense you get a healthy
jimmy garoppolo sky's the limit for
antonio brown in that offense and and
that that i think that's the no-brainer
best destination because it's where he
wants to be and i think what he wants is
a key factor in all of this that too
many people are overlooking he doesn't
want pittsburgh he wants san francisco
that's the best fit is there any part of
you though that says pittsburgh is going
to sit here and be a little salty that
antonio brown wants out so badly and the
compensation might not be great that
they're like you know what we're not
going to give antonio brown what he
wants he wants to go to the 49ers we're
going to make sure he doesn't go to the
49ers well and look that is you know the
steelers way is to tell players how it's
going to be and it's it's very out of
character for the steelers to be in this
position the past few years between
le'veon bell and antonio brown where the
players are telling them how it's going
to be and i still hold out the
possibility that the steelers are
eventually going to say you know what
screw this
we can't afford to set this precedent
where any star player thinks if you make
enough noise you get what you want we're
going to slam this door in his face and
we're telling him just like the vikings
told adrian peterson a few years ago
when he wanted out of minnesota hey you
got two choices you play for us or you
play for no one and if you choose to
play for no one you're going to owe us
11.4 million dollars that we've already
paid you in signing bonus money that you
haven't earned yet and you're not going
to get any more money from us you're not
going to get any money from anyone so if
you're unhappy deal with it a lot of
people are unhappy this is where you are
this is where you've been and this is
where you'll be and uh you better shape
up as well because we're going to start
finding you and we're going to
discipline you and things are going to
be different i i could i still think
there's a chance that's what the
steelers resolve to do even if antonio
brown doesn't want that so how do we do
the rest of this draft because i just
checkmated you and you literally just
gave me all the defense of my first pick
you just backed up my first pick do we
end the draft right now
i didn't that doesn't mean it's the best
fit for him i could see the steelers
playing that card even though it's not
in their best interest to do it i think
it's in my best interest to just move on
from this guy because their respect
here's the thing big cat they're
responsible for creating this monster
i'm filibustering right now yeah this
was a six-round guy from one of the
directional michigan schools who comes
to pittsburgh as a guy who's just trying
to make it onto the roster they let him
become this guy who has a separate set
of rules who comes and goes as he
pleases who shows up late whenever he
feels like it who has a separate rental
house in latrobe and doesn't stay in the
dorm with his teammates they allowed it
to exist so if they're going to get all
sanctimonious about it now they need to
look in the mirror and say this is kind
of our fault that it's reached the point
of no return so let's just chalk this
one up to bad bad planning and bad
performance on our part and let this guy
leave all right i'm just happy that you
decided to get into this profession and
leave your lawyer years behind because
you are the worst lawyer of all time oh
really my second pick
i mean i i didn't i i'm the guy who
skips jury duty and i'm just bodybagging
you left and right
i i'm polite to you because you're the
guest if this is how it's going to be
then i'm going to start coming with
sharpened claws
and
teeth bared and ready to go all right
all right i'm going to do my next pick
i'm going to go with the jets i think
le'veon bell and antonio brown will be
perfect together on the jets they have a
100 million or close to 100 million
dollars in cap space the jets new york i
feel like they're the type of franchise
that will take a risk on a guy like
antonio brown they have an offensive
coach now they have to put weapons
around sam darnold because they drafted
him in the first round i think antonio
brown le'veon bell are going to both be
new york jets next year
yeah here's the thing though i can't
imagine adam gase wanting antonio brown
he got rid of jarvis landry because he
thought landry was selfish landry's
nothing compared to antonio brown and i
think with brown um you know if you're
going to bring him through the door and
you're going to tell him how it's going
to be and you're going to discipline him
and you're going to hold him accountable
i don't know maybe he wants that in a
weird sort of a way and he never got it
in pittsburgh from mike tomlin i don't
know maybe he'll respond to it well but
i think gase is going to have misgivings
about having antonio brown around is
that is that a better
did i
the case or okay all right thank you
maybe i may get my law license back now
all right i'm going to go with
you know and we're talking about best
fit right
i'm going to go with the cardinals
even though they're not good they need a
star player and he would be he would be
happy there i think he would be
appreciated there they need this as
larry fitzgerald gets closer and closer
to the end who do the cardinals really
have and there's only so much they can
do via draft picks i think from a from a
franchise's standpoint that a few years
ago was dangerously close to becoming a
national brand which i never would have
dreamed the cardinals like i got a
nephew a 14 year old nephew who loves
the cardinals um you pair him up with
patrick peterson you get a you got josh
rosen at quarterback you got david
johnson's got some years left i think it
could be interesting in arizona okay uh
not a bad pick not a great pick but not
a bad pick uh i'm gonna go with my last
pick
the green bay packers i think aaron
rodgers will say get me help get me help
now if it's the seventh rounder go get
antonio brown
and guess what if you have a mercurial
quarterback you can have a mercurial i'm
not even saying the word correctly wide
receiver everyone can just be really
salty altogether and if you're talking
about fit there it is there's your
perfect fit and i'm not saying that
because i want antonio brown to go to
the packers and you know explode trojan
horse trojan horse trojan horse as soon
as you said it as soon as you said it i
knew what you were up to yes packers
you're setting them up yeah great um
i'm gonna stay in the nfc west first of
all you you nailed mercurial you nailed
it twice uh boom
nfc west
la rams every year they find a way to
make a move where we're like oh the whoa
who would have thought that i think the
ram the rams were interested in odell
beckham last year i know they have
brandon cooks but you know robert woods
uh okay move you know
maybe it's time to move on from robert
woods antonio brown brandon cook's
cooper cup that i i think we're going to
see the rams do something big and bold
to make us forget about the three points
in the super bowl and this would be the
thing to do it and i think antonio brown
would be happy there a team that just
made it the super bowl and he's in you
know it's not it's not uh san francisco
but uh close enough it's only 500 miles
away all right we got to take a break
big cat's got steelers jets packers i've
got 49ers cardinals rams i win he loses
we'll wrap up pft library after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports